D
BIOLOGICAL ME ALSOONTINUE
DOMINANG WOMEN'S SPORTS.
MADISON KENYON I A COLLEGE
TRACKTHLETE W ALSO COMPEDAGAINSY
KRTIN WAGNER.
THK YOU BOTH F BEING WIT
US.
IHOUL S WHILE LEAH THOMAS
HASN'T HADENDER SURGERY H DID
HAVE A YEAR'S WORTH OF HORMONA
TREATMWHIC IS WHAT IREQUIREDT DT
BIOLOGICAL FAC THAT H IA
MAN.
HE WENT THRGHURSUANT AS A
HEAS MCLE STRUCTU AND
EVERYTHING THRGH 22 YEARS OF
HIS LIFE A A MAN.
MADIN, HAVE YOU COMPETED
AGAINST THIS EXACT SITUATIONN
TRAC
YO HAVE COMPETED AGAINST
TRSGENDER ATHLETES.
>> YEAH.I THINKISSED YOUR QUEION
CAUSE ITLICH.
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO ASK IT AIN.
>> Wl: SE, WOULD YOU TL
L OF US WATCHING RHT NOW
WHAT IS ITIKE TOO IO A
COMPITION AGAINST A
TRSGENR ATHLE WN YOUKNOW THE OU?
>> YEAH, IT'S EXTREMELY
FLATG.
HAVEXPERIEEDT FIVETIMES.
AN EACH TIME I LT TO
BIOGICAL MALE.
D THE FACT THA THAT IS STILLHAPL
LOSINGO BIOLOGICA MALENLESS
THR OWN SPORTHOWS WHY WE
NEEDOREEMALE ATHLES TO
SPEA UP ABOUTHIS.I WANT TO SAY T
T ANYONE SENCEOU.
SPEA UP.
TELLHE NCAA YOURTHLETIC
DIRECTORS A YOU COAES THAT
U WANTS FR COMPETI
BECAUSE DOINGHIS IS NOWHE
NEAR AS SCARY AS IT SEEMS ANDTHS
OVWHELMING.>> Will: DISO I'M JUT
CURIOUS, YOU RANRACK, RIG?
WHAT YRVENT?
>> SO I DID THE 3 K INDR TRACK
AND THE500 AND I ALSO RAN
CROSS-COUNY.
>>ill: WHEN DIDOU STARTRUNNING?N
TRACK HOW OLD WERE YOU.
>> IT GLICHED.
I RAN --'M SORRY, Y WILL
VE TO ASK THE QUESTN.
I DON KNOWHAT YOU ASKED?
>> Will: I WL ASK YOU ONE MORE
TIME A SEE I WE CAN WORK
THROUGH THI GLITCH.
HOW OLD A YOU WHEN YOU STARTED
AINING FOR COMPETITION IN
TRK?
OH, STAED CROSS-CNTRY
IN MIDDLE SCHOO AND TRACK IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
SO AROUND 14.
>> Wil SO YOU STARTED TININ
ATHE AGE OF 1
D WITHIN A MATTER O I WOU
ASSUME A COUE MONTHS A
BIOLOGICAL METEPPED IN A
AT YOU AER ALLF YOUR YRSOF TRAI.
>> YEA
SO MY FIRST COLLEGIATEACE IRATIL
MALEND TY BEATE.>> Wl: TO YOUR T
EVANS, MSYRANKLIN, KATIE
LEDECKY SOMEBOD HASO STEP U
AND Y THIS IS N RIG THIS
♪ RIGHTMRS. WAGNER IOULDOVE TO T
W OTHIS.
I MENTIONED WHATHE NA RUL
E ABOUT HORNAL TREATMENT AND
DIFFERTTATES, HIGH SOOLLEVEL HE.
WH SHOULD THEAWS B WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS?
>> THE ARE SPLE, THE LAW
SHOULD BE THA BIOLOGIL WOMEN
COMPET AGAINST BIOLOGICAL
WOMEN.
AN THE NCA PICY DOESN'T
QUIRE THE UNIRSITY OF
PENNSYR
PLAYING FIE TO WEN.
IT DOESN'T REQRE THAT A ALL.
IN FAC WHAIT IS DNG IS
PRIORIZINGCTIVISTS OVER
WOMEN ATHLETES AND BY DENYING
EM A FR PLAYINGIELD THEY
ARE RUSIN AGAIN, TO
RECOIZE LEGITIME BIOLOGICA
DISTINCTIONS A THAT HUR
MENND GIRLS THE MOS
>> Will: YOU KNOW,ND I THINK
MARE GUIDED BY EMPAT.BUT PORITIE
HUREDS, THE THOANDS OF
MADISONS OUT THERE TT HAVE
AINED THEIR EIRE LIFE.
>> WAVE SELECVE IN WHEREYOU APPY
BY THE WAY IT' THE END OF